We want to take, an offline first approach to building
web apps, where your app can work offline by default.
Don't be fooled, into thinking offline, can be an afterthought,
just because we left this lesson to the end. Offline support,
in the web platform, is a very complex topic, which
is why we saved to the last. But first, let's
define, what offline really means. There are a number of
different scenarios, that can cause someone to be offline. These typically
boil down, to not having a radio or Wi-Fi connection. But,
not all of these scenarios, can be detected, by making a connection
attempt. It's good to keep this in mind and all the
more reason, to build apps, that treat the network as an enhancement.